foreign
schools of this country are facing a
massive wave of retirements with almost
a quarter million teachers likely to
leave the classroom for good when this
school year is over but there is one
math teacher in Virginia Lou coconis 91
years old and he is not among them in
fact retirement is not even on his radar
Scott McFarland shows us how his
dedication has ex has inspired at this
point really Generations plural of
students
hits the treadmill most mornings to keep
up his endurance and his strength for a
career that must feel something like a
marathon now in his 90s coconis is in
his 63rd year teaching math at
Alexandria City High School in Northern
Virginia divide by two and that adds up
to thousands of students 6 400 students
some of them are doctors and lawyers you
teach the children of your former
students do you teach the grandchildren
of your former students I I think I had
one he's also had students like Mark
Eisenhower become fellow teachers and
then beat him to retirement and he'd
been here nearly 30 years you graduated
you had a 30-year career you retired
he's still here
how is that possible yeah I didn't think
it was possible I didn't think it was I
thought he was close to retirement when
I was a student here it's only possible
because coconis first entered these
Halls before the Beatles form this rock
and roll group has taken over before
space travel
and back when there were only 48 states
the calculus coconis teaches hasn't
changed how many got this one right but
his calculus had to because coconis says
today's students hold new challenges
right in their hands it's not easy
trying to
keep them from using their cell phone
they're addictive okay you all want to
look over your tests but it's his old
school approach of offering free
tutoring on Saturdays and being the
first to arrive each day which connects
with his students to be working and
teaching for this long and to still like
put in all this extra effort on
Saturdays I really admire that about him
and while the pay is a lot better than
the 4 800 a year coconis first made in
1959 it's still significantly lower than
other jobs requiring college degrees one
study showed teacher in principle stress
is twice that of other professions
Mentor some of the younger teachers and
they must look to you for advice well
I'll look to them for computer help does
anybody know what the answers with no
wife or children coconis devotes himself
completely to his students If I Had a
Wife she'd probably leave me within a
week I mean I'm sitting there working
all night trying to grade papers and
don't have time to run around
and he insists retirement is not one of
the three R's he'll consider I don't
think that way I just
my mind has said that I'm going to do
well this year and I'm going to enjoy it
and I'm going to try to come next year
if they'll take me for CBS mornings I'm
Scott McFarland in Alexandria Virginia
yes I like when he said I need them to
help me with the computer but he clearly
still knows his stuff I love watching
him at the board and doing out those
complicated problems and I think that is
part I gotta believe that is part of
what keeps you young and active if your
mind is going all the time because I
don't understand anything
exactly I see E equals mc2 that's all I
squared yeah mc2 clearly it was called
sorry on TV